bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
dopage dans l'équipe cycliste festina
était organisée pour l'achat et la
distribution de produits prohibés
révélation du soignant de festina willy
voûte qui mettait en cause richard
virenque son avocate raïssi doublement
des unités hospitalières de soins
palliatifs a lancé par bernard kouchner
qui veut organiser un nouveau rituel de
fin de vie l'annulation par la cour
d'appel de paris d'un accord sur le
temps de travail conclut edf gdf
remettent en cause des milliers
d'embauchés notre dossier spécial dans
cette édition qui sera consacré à
l'allemagne à la veille d'élections
générales au sommaire le portrait du
challenger d'helmut kohl
le social démocrate gerhard schröder le
témoignage de chefs d'entreprises
français en allemagne et allemand en
france l'exemple le rappel de l'histoire
politique de nos deux pays et des
couples une politique franco allemand et
puis l'exemple d'un mariage mixte franco
allemand tout cela en direct avec la
participation notamment de mesurer les
riches giscard d'estaing et puis
j'ajouterai à ces titres une bonne
nouvelle à l'hôpital du val de grâce à
paris le ministre de l'intérieur jean
pierre chevènement n'est plus sous
assistance respiratoire il peut parler
mais il reste pour l'instant sous
dialyse dans l'équipe cycliste festina
le dopage était très précisément
organisé celui qui était à l'origine des
procédures judiciaires déclenchées dès
le départ du tour de france au début du
mois de juillet le soigneur de l'équipe
festina monsieur ville et vous tu
affirmes que richard vient de se doper
bien et que les autres coureurs ne
pouvait être dopée à leur insu le
soigneur donne d'autres détails qu'il
puise dans ses carnets personnels les
voici explications philippe visseyrias
philippe ges la voilà vous voyez
tour de france 97 qu'est ce que richard
virenque il a eu le s'être laissé
séduire par don
ep en 2000 et puis en 2008 juillet alors
ils se retrouvent aussi là avec deux
unités d'hormones de croissance
le 8 juillet aussi après on a le 10
juillet il
c'est un agenda de 1997 sur lequel willy
vous inscrire toutes les injections de
produits dopants administré aux coureurs
de festina à la page du tour de france
on retrouve le nom de richard virenque
presque tous les jeunes aux dp au rouge
versés pour moins de croissance donc
pour le masseur de l'équipe festina
c'est la preuve que richard virenque ça
c'est bien doper juillet ils m'attaquent
il faut que je réponde maintenant ça
suffit alors c'est pour ça ça me fait
mal aux cours parce que j'ai quand même
resté trois jours sans rien dire quand
je me suis fait arrêter
alors maintenant je peux plus ému et au
bord des larmes
vu les voûtes et est aujourd'hui
convoqué par la commission de discipline
de la fédération française de cyclisme
pris dans un tourbillon judiciaire le
soigneur de l'équipe festina n'a de
cesse de se justifier moi je suis
minceur alors je vois des choses et j'ai
transporté des choses interdit et
j'assume
c'est tout mais je suis ça qui me
révolte que on dit que je suis un
trafiquant que je suis un dealer pour
des objectifs
alors là ça me révolte et ça je prends
pas depuis 1993 oui les voûtes tient la
comptabilité exacte des produits
interdits pris par les coureurs de
festina son nom là l'agenda de 1988 mais
aux mains du juge chargé de
l'instruction ceux des années
précédentes n'ont pas été saisis par la
justice
ils contiennent pourtant d'après willy
voûte d'autres éléments accablants
alors que prouvent ses carnets qui
sombrait pas ce cap a tous moi aussi je
peux crayonné sur un carnet un peu de
tout ce que je bats je suis tout à fait
prêt à ce que maître collard qui lui
ressemblerait bien notre colère c'est
votre collègue opposés celui qui les
fait environ c'est celui qui me
contraint aujourd'hui à m'exprimer
devant vous en massacrant c'est un
règlement de comptes entre avocats pas
seulement non non pas du tout pas du
tout il ya des convictions anti dopage
qui sont partagées par mon client et
moi-même qui jouent un rôle dans ce que
nous sommes en train de faire devant vos
caméras
mais alors que prouve réellement ses
carnets ben ses carnets combiné avec les
commentaires que désormais mon client
willy voet accepte d'en faire sont une
preuve irréfutable de ce que monsieur
virenque s'est dopé mais je veux dire
qu' il n'était pas dans mon intention de
le dire tous les cas de le dire si vite
j'ai attendu d'y être contraint sa part
une menace c'est un peu une clause de
style d'homme de droit mais ce que ce
que je veux dire c'est pourquoi est ce
que il ya déjà eu un carnet qui a été
saisi par la justice
pourquoi est ce que ceux ci ont été
dissimulés à la justice je tiens à la
disposition de la justice
certainement la portion des carnets
concernant richard virenque puisque à
l'égard de richard virenque je suis pour
a parlé simplement en situation et mon
client aussi de défense légitime de
légitime défense
je suis contraint d'établir la vérité
donc je vous réponds il n'y a pas de
problème que le juge les demandes les
pages concernant l'irak sont à sa
disposition
mais vous en voulait particulièrement
virenque pas ce que lui dit qu'il ne
sait pas de paix pas du tout pas du tout
je crois que chacun est libre de choisir
son système de défense
d'ailleurs il a marqué un point
aujourd'hui plus la fédération française
de cyclisme a ajourné signer dié les
auditions des coureurs et notamment de
virac ne sera pas sélectionné pour les
championnats du monde
c'est ce que l'on dit je pense que le
règlement d'après lequel ne peut pas
être sélectionné pour le championnat du
monde fera l'objet d'un recours et sera
invalidée ça ne tient pas la route toute
personne qui n'est pas jugée présumée
innocente je dirais pas el-assad en tout
cas j'ai chris vince ferment donc la
parenthèse aujourd'hui donc il a
partiellement progresser dans ce système
consistant à nier les évidences virenque
il nie les évidences moi je n'ai rien
contre pourvu que il ne se livre pas à
une agression injuste et très grave pour
mon client sur procès verbal
et même si il n'est pas crédible parce
qu'il est le seul parmi 198 participants
au tour de france si je ne me trompe il
est le seul à avoir qualifié mon client
de dealers de personnes qui faisaient
des profits contre toutes les évidences
mais même si cela n'est pas
vraisemblable
par principe je ne peux pas l'accepter
déjà je ne pouvais pas l'accepter mais
alors j'accepte encore moins
qu'aujourd'hui j'apprenne par voie de
presse que je serait paraît-il le
traîner en justice auprès du procureur
de lille si je ne me trompe
on n'a rien dit pour l'instant je
demande à voir mans va rester c'est
peut-être un coup de bluff monter sa
cote et linge sale qu'on lave dans les
médias parce que au fond tout le monde
se rejette la responsabilité de ce
dopage qui était quand même sciemment et
délibérément organisé par votre client
notamment cheveux
non je n'accepte pas la sq de lynchage
je retiendrai le mot de légitime défense
face à deux attaques successives de
monsieur vie rinck la première
consistant à nous salir la deuxième
consistante nous attaquer ce qui est
quand même d'un paradoxe extraordinaire
c'est le monde à l'envers et je
retiendrai par ailleurs le fait que nous
avons la même aversion la même
répugnance mon client et moi même temps
pour la délation peu pour le dopage et
vous pourriez me dire pourtant vous
parlons nous ne parlons que en réponse à
virenque
notre principe c'est être contre la
délation et être contre le dopage
nous avons des rejets le principe
hostile à la délation en réponse avis
rent
nous restons foncièrement hostiles au
dopage et mon client a déjà donné 16
jours d'emprisonnement ce qui est très
dur c'est pas bien qui pourrait en dire
autant dire un qui gagne 30 fois plus
d'argent à fond c'était n'a pas fait les
jeux ne sait pas que je lui souhaite pas
du tout mais en tous les cas un peu de
pudeur dans la disproportion dans leur
équilibre des forces
un vilain que l'enfant gâté le vrai
patron de festina qui veut accabler mon
client gratuitement cela amène forcément
une riposte c'est celle que grâce à vous
je peux faire publiquement aujourd'hui
merci nous suivons ce dossier d'autant
plus que le directeur sportif de
l'équipe tv m est attendue par la
justice belge et puis à noter que la
commission antidopage
la fédération cycliste suisse va
demander auprès de l'union cycliste
internationale une suspension de six
mois pour trois coureurs suisses de
festina avec soul laurent dufaux et
armin meier pour mieux accompagner la
fin de vie de secrétaire d'état à la
santé monsieur bernard kouchner veut
renforcer l'action publique en faveur
des soins palliatifs et de la lutte
contre la douleur
monsieur kouchner ne croit pas
nécessaire une loi sur l'euthanasie mais
veut promouvoir des soins
d'accompagnements un rituel pour
reprendre son expression qui éviterait
un site de légiférer trop vite
le nombre d'unités de soins palliatifs
devrait doubler explications benoît
thevenet pascal couillaud une vie qui
s'achève dans un service de soins
palliatifs les traitements lourds ont
été stoppées il reste quelques jours
quelques semaines à vivre un temps
consacré à l'accompagnement du mourant
et au soulagement de ses souffrances
bien 50 unités telles que celles ci
existent en france
au total 450 lits largement insuffisant
l'objectif du plan présenté par bernard
kouchner est de généraliser la prise en
charge des malades en fin de vie pour
cela des crédits vont être débloqués
entre 50 et 100 millions de francs pour
doubler le nombre d'unités de soins
palliatifs en france
les hôpitaux qui développeront ce genre
de service seront également encouragés
car jusqu'ici le nombre de décès était
un critère d'évaluation des
établissements hospitaliers
il est vrai que tous les sens deux
antennes l'accueil patients gravement
atteints alors c'est sûr que s'ils ont
choisi d'accueillir des patients pas
trop gravement atteints on a une
mortalité qui est moindre et ça n'est
pas un bon critère pour juger d'un
établissement je trouve qu'un
établissement qui acceptent de soigner
d'accueillir les patients les plus
gravement atteints c'est quelque chose
qui est tout à fait loi donc il ne faut
pas que ce soit un critère péjoratif les
mesures s'attache aussi à améliorer
l'accompagnement lui même des soins
palliatifs pourront être prodigués à
domicile pour certains malades
et puis la création de congé pour
accompagner un proche qui va mourir est
à l'étude
faut que l'on créé dans un pays comme le
nôtre un pays moderne où on a cru
évacuer la mort où ça se passe à
l'hôpital de façon un peu dissimulée
espèce de naturelles d'environnement de
tendresse d'accompagnement médical
religieux sont chouettes associatif mais
sa famille surtout il faut que les
proches soient là il soins palliatifs
auront trouvé véritablement leur place
quand ils ne seront plus cantonnée aux
seuls services spécialisés et que
l'ensemble du corps médical en fera une
priorité depuis ce matin dans les
pharmacies le vaccin contre la grippe
est en vente comme chaque année une
campagne nationale d'information sur la
vaccination anti grippale est lancé il y
aurait en moyenne 2500 baisse est
imputable aux conséquences de la grippe
parmi les personnes âgées de plus de 75
ans et puis à signer que les
anesthésistes des hôpitaux publics et
des cliniques privées seront en grève
demain et après-demain seules les
urgences seront assurées à l'assemblée
nationale devant la commission des lois
premier examen pour la proposition de
pacte civil de solidarité le taxent
l'examen en séance plénière aura lieu le
9 octobre mais le texte est examiné dès
aujourd'hui ce pacte obéit à plusieurs
motivations et devrait sécuriser les
couples vivant hors mariage reportage
sophie mais elle valérie criton brigitte
44 ans a été mariée 7 ans et et il ya
longtemps
patrick 42 ans son compagnon
d'aujourd'hui une quinzaine d'années de
vie commune en union libre comme on dit
pour moi le mariage a toujours
représenté une institution réactionnaire
donc je n'étais pas un choix
mon choix de vie court il se retrouve
donc comme des millions de français unis
sans jamais être passé devant monsieur
le maire
aucun contrat de lily l'un à l'autre
ensemble ils ont pourtant un enfant
knicks 10 ans et un petit patrimoine
seuls biens communs que nous aimions le
sait la maison donc effectivement on a
pensé à ce type de situation sans
trouver de solution réelle n'a pas géré
en termes de droit y aurait pas comment
régler les problèmes d'héritage qui
fatalement surviendront un jour hors
mariage ils devront acquitter 60 % de
droits de mutation sur la part de
l'autre à moins qu'il ne souscrivent un
pacs un pacte civil de solidarité
le texte prévoit que les co signataires
pourront alors se léguer 300 mille
francs sans droits de succession
j'ai pas le sentiment quand même ça va
modifier une manière très très important
de j si l'on ait souscrit sur les soucis
le pacs ne se veut qu'un choix
supplémentaire pour tous les concubins
il est pourtant attaqué fustigé de
toutes parts pour l'église il serait un
mariage au rabais ou pire encore un
mariage homosexuel qui ne dirait pas son
nom pour les homosexuels il s'agit tout
simplement d'une mesure de justice
si cette mesure passe et je souhaite
qu'elle passe bien entendu la france
sera un des pays au monde qui offrira le
cadre légal le plus juste le plus
équitable au couple
quelles que soient les coupes
le pacs ne prévoit de régler que des
problèmes bassement matérielles droit au
bail imposition ou succession et l'amour
dans tout ça ce n'est pas le propos ni
amour ni fidélité officiellement même
deux amis pourront souscrire un pacte
en corse au lendemain des menaces
proférées par un groupe clandestin
contre l'état français une autre lettre
de menaces de mort a été adressée cette
fois président de la chambre
d'agriculture de la corse-du-sud
apparemment il n'y a pas de lien entre
les deux mais le président de la chambre
d'agriculture monsieur rené mme oda a
reçu une lettre manuscrite comportant le
numéro d'une arme volée à la mairie
d'ajaccio c'était au début du mois
d'août commentaires valérie fournier
rené mode a décidé de répondre aux
menaces devant la presse
il montre la lettre qu'il a reçue hier
le texte des amis ne peuvent plus de
protéger tu as trop parler on retrouvera
bientôt à côté de ton cadavre
leluc heures 15 596 144 pour quoi nous
attendre et ce communiqué je vous pose
la question
il n'est pas question que je sois traité
différemment d'un autre citoyens de
sept-îles
j'assume mes responsabilités les tailles
la faire respecter
la paix civile dans cette île qu'il
fasse son boulot je veux pas de
protection particulière
nous avons condamné malgré de
précédentes menaces rené mode avait
participé récemment aux rapports glavany
sur la corse
nous avons fait des propositions je dois
revenir avec un jeu sans reprise en
partie dans le rapport
nous en sommes fiers et nous continuons
à les soutenir donc pour ce qui est de
nous faire taire si la lettre et pour
dire que le monde agricole le
syndicalisme d'accord du sud basse terre
ce ne sera pas le président de la
chambre d'agriculture va continuer à
vivre protégé par quelques amis
nationalistes ajaccio en tout cas ce
soir
la sécurité a été renforcée auprès
d'autres personnalités politiques et
quelques magistrats
l'ancien président du crédit lyonnais
monsieur jean yves haberer a été mis en
examen ce contrôle judiciaire il s'est
vu notifier les infractions de
présentation de comptes inexacts et de
diffusion de fausse information
monsieur à braire a fait savoir que
c'est à sa demande qu'il avait été mis
en examen mais il est également mis en
examen pour abus de biens sociaux il fut
président du crédit lyonnais de 88 à 93
commentaire hervé brusini le dossier
crédit lyonnais n'a pas fini de faire
rugir
lui c'est dans le silence judiciaire
qu'il russie le juge zanotto homme fort
discret a horreur qu'on reste silencieux
lorsqu'il pose des questions certes
grâce à de multiples perquisitions des
documents en parlait mais le magistrat
s'interroge sur un point bien précis
par quel miracle la banque at-elle
révélé en 94 d'énormes pertes alors que
les bilans des trois années précédentes
étaient bénéficiaires
autrement dit à ton trafic et les
comptes c'est la plus grande lan mise en
examen par le juge pour présentation de
comptes inexacts
j'aurai à braire fut le patron du
lyonnais de 88 à 93
il n'y a pas si longtemps il savait se
faire menaçant ces comptes sont établis
avec la banque de france avec le trésor
nous sommes surveillés par la cour des
comptes par la commission bancaire donc
que tout le monde regarde que toutes ces
cartes sont mis sur table et on verra
comment ça s'est passé
justement quand il fait les
administrateurs civils
les membres de la commission bancaire
les commissaires aux comptes
pourquoi n'ont ils rien dit alors que
les milliards s'évaporait il est vrai
qu'au plus haut niveau
le marchandage été 2010 on a le
président de la banque dit mais résultat
pour moi c'est plus un milliard de
francs le commissaire aux comptes qui
dit ah non monsieur le président c'est
moins 3 milliards
et puis on coupe la poire en deux on dit
va finalement d'irak la banque a gagné 2
milliards et tout le monde de s'entendre
sur le dos du contribuable car à
l'époque le politique couvre françois
gilles entendu aujourd'hui par les
policiers était l'homme des dossiers
sensibles
pour lui il y avait consignes pour
minimiser les pertes du lyonnais
la banque de france et non les banques
se sont réunis pour considérer ce
problème et pour chaque pour chercher
comment le traiter
comptablement d'une manière qui ne
risque pas d'aggraver la crise dans la
galerie financière du palais de justice
80 instructions sont en cours sur le
lyonnais derrière les portes les
dossiers rugissent en silence un accord
sur les 32 heures à edf gdf était
annulée par la cour d'appel de paris
cette décision qui a surpris toutes les
parties entraîne la suspension de toutes
nouvelles embauches
les magistrats ont estimé que l'accord
était dérogatoire au code du travail
conformément à la demande de la cgt
force ouvrière cette décision de justice
fragilise les emplois déjà créé
explications pascal golomer sébastien
guibert patrons et syndicats d'edf gdf
côte à côte
l'image n'est pas si fréquent ce c'était
en janvier 97
l'accord sur le passage au 32 eur venait
d'être signé par la cfdt la cgc et la
cftc 32 heures au lieu de 38 mais payer
au moins 35 un accord qui devait
permettre de créer quinze mille emplois
en trois ans 5000 jeunes ont d'ailleurs
étaient déjà embauché sur la base des
trente deux heures et près de 20 mille
salariés ont choisi de réduire leur
temps de travail
un accord contre lequel se sont toujours
battus la cgt majoritaire et force
ouvrière
parce qu'il créerait un nouveau statut
du personnel différent du statut de 1946
après 20 mois de bataille juridique la
cour d'appel de paris leur a donc donné
raison
l'accord est contraire aux statuts il
est annulé une très mauvaise surprise
pour la direction qui avait parié sur
cet accord pour réorganiser le travail
dans ses agences dans un communiqué elle
annonce qu'elle suspend toute nouvelle
embauche tout nouveau passage à temps
réduit
la cgt elle même a été surprise par
cette invalidation
elle compte désormais négocier le
passage aux 35 heures mais sans
réduction de salaire
mais vous verrez que les jeunes veulent
travailler à temps complet ils veulent
pas un salaire réduit via s'ils veulent
travailler moins longtemps c'est ce que
nous proposons travailler 35 heures voix
et 32 heures david ils veulent passer
les réduit surprise aussi à la cfdt
déception surtout elle qui avait le
sentiment d'avoir signé un accord
novateur proposer à des jeunes qui sont
sur le marché de l'emploi qui sont
actuellement au chômage ou dans la
précarité de rentrer à edf sur la base
de 32 heures payées 36 caisses qui ne
voudrait pas pouvoir le faire
aujourd'hui nous avons privés de cette
possibilité des milliers de jeunes
salaire ou emploi la justice vient en
tout cas se mêler de façon spectaculaire
au débat sur les 35 heures dans les
entreprises publiques
monsieur lionel jospin a fait souvent en
fin d'après midi qu'il autorisait le
redémarrage de la centrale nucléaire edf
de belleville sur loire dans le
département du cher
les deux réacteurs de cette centrale
était à l'arrêt depuis le mois de juin
pour une question d'étanchéité à la
suite de la présentation par madame
martine aubry du projet de loi sur le
financement de la sécurité sociale et
notamment de la gestion du système de
santé en prévision d'un équilibre des
comptes de la sécurité sociale l'année
prochaine de nombreuses réactions
étaient enregistrés les médecins
généralistes de mg france parle
d'avancés sur le plan des réformes
structurelles la confédération des
syndicats médicaux français fait part de
son inquiétude est tandis que le parti
socialiste appelle à la mobilisation de
tous les acteurs du système de santé le
rpr évoque l' arbitraire et l'absence de
perspectives cohérente
alors on a souvent tenté de comparer la
méthode et les moyens utilisés
respectivement par alain juppé martine
aubry pour résoudre ce problème du
déficit de la sécurité sociale
voici une comparaison des deux
politiques en ce qui concerne le monde
médical
pour martine aubry il faut protéger la
france du plan juppé
mais aux yeux des médecins sa réforme
elle n'est pas si différent dans le plan
juppé les sanctions consistait en une
amende
les médecins devant reversés à la sécu
le trop perçu par rapport aux objectifs
de dépenses dans le plan aubry la
sanction en cas de dépassement sera une
hausse de leurs cotisations sociales par
ailleurs alain juppé avait voulu fixer
région par région l'enveloppent des
dépenses alors que martine aubry
préférant rester un objectif national
du coup sous le précédent gouvernement
tous les médecins d'une région trop
dépensière était sanctionné désormais la
distinction se fera entre généralistes
et spécialistes les 1 ne devront pas
payer pour les autres
question de nuance donc d'ailleurs ceux
qui dénonçaient le plan juppé vilipende
aujourd'hui le plan aubry et ceux qui
acceptent la réforme d'aujourd'hui
soutenait déjà celle d'hier ce
gouvernement après avoir réfléchi
pendant de l'ombre 18 mois a dessiné de
la compléter cette réforme sur des
éléments structurants pour le système de
soins et dans ce sens là c'est ce qui
nous permet d'accepter ou de subir une
clause de régulation économique les
médecins n'aiment pas quand il ya
dépassement de ses objectifs et bien
persiste les reversements les sanctions
collectives de toute la profession
médicale
on désire une fois de plus un coupable
et ceux coupables et pénaliser qu'ils
soient bons ou qu'il soit mauvais la
réforme au bruit et elle promise à un
avenir aussi agitée que le plan juppé
premier élément de réponse dès demain
les syndicats négocieront ici avec la
caisse d'assurance maladie
le montant des budgets à ne pas dépasser
pour chaque filière médicale préavis de
grève de syndicats de personnels d'air
france sont trois syndicats minoritaires
de pilotes le trafic passagers d'air
france pourrait être légèrement perturbé
demain
et puis à orly un mouvement de grève de
l'ensemble des syndicats de personnels
d'aéroports de paris pourrait également
entraîner une modification du trafic en
espagne hier les députés ont rejeté par
173 voix contre 160 12 et une abstention
une proposition du bordeaux juriste
espagnol pour libéraliser l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse les conditions
l'avortement en espagne depuis 85 1985
sont très strictement encadrée par la
loi les conservateurs au pouvoir et
l'église catholique espagnole ont bien
sûr encourager le vote compte
une pétition internationale en faveur du
président américain bill clinton des
personnalités de la culture des sciences
du monde entier à l'initiative de
jacques lang ont publié dans le journal
le monde un appel à soutenir le
président des états unis estimant que la
démocratie est doublement menacée parmi
les signataires des prix nobel comme
desmond tout gabriel garcia marquez et
pierre gilles de gennes mais aussi des
artistes depardieu jeanne moreau alain
delon entre autres robert altman sophia
loren ou encore des romanciers et des
musiciens très célèbre en belgique
très vite critiqué on demande la
démission du ministre l'intérieur après
le décès d'une réfugiée
ian jeune femme de 20 ans lors son
expulsion elle s'est débattue dans
l'avion qui devait la ramener au nigeria
on lui appliquer un coussin sur la
bouche et elle est morte d'une
hémorragie cérébrale il ya des
manifestations à bruxelles et le
ministre de l'intérieur a exprimé ce si
ce qui s'est passé hier est le jour le
plus noir de ma carrière politique deux
gendarmes belges ont été inculpées
d'homicide à saint dominique et haïti
l'ouragan george qui avait épargné la
guadeloupe fait des ravages et
provoquent des morts une école a été
emportée par un glissement de terrain à
saint domingue
quarante personnes ont disparu à haïti
un bilan provisoire fait état de 13
morts tandis que des pluies très
importantes continuent de tomber sur le
pays l'ouragan george se dirige
maintenant vers la floride puis deux
équipes de spécialistes de la sécurité
civile française se sont rendus en haïti
et à saint denis voilà nous allons
ouvrir maintenant notre dossier spécial
consacré à l'allemagne
à quatre jours des élections
législatives dimanche 27 septembre
nous évoquerons les relations entre la
france et l'allemagne notamment avec
monsieur giscard d'estaing mais aussi
nos situations économiques croisés avec
des chefs d'entreprise nous tenterons de
comprendre nos différences européenne
mais pour commencer
voyons l'aspect politique depuis 16 ans
le chancelier kohl est au pouvoir il est
menacé par le candidat social démocrate
gerhard schröder
celui ci est âgé de 54 ans il est le
président du lander de basse-saxe dans
le nord du pays
alors nous allons faire plus amplement
se connaît sa connaissance avec le
portrait dressé par olivier werner
rythme
ducharme garage fraudeurs c'est d'abord
forgé une image avant toute chose les
idées la répartition des réformes on
verra plus tard
grand séducteur avec ses yeux bleus très
agréable à écouter avec sa voix posée
gerhard schröder a peu à peu emballé son
histoire vous avez les campagnes
électorales
une offensive tous azimuts à travers le
pays d'est en ouest comme devant les
cadres du parti
garracio d'heure a su séduire les
décideurs les industriels les ouvriers
les chômeurs hausse pourtant monsieur le
ministre président de la basse saxe n'a
jamais été cité comme faisant partie des
meilleurs gestionnaires on l'a surnommé
le camarade des patrons on la
soupçonnait de vouloir prendre le
pouvoir à n'importe quel prix
d'allemagne
je pense qu'un homme peut aussi toujours
le produit de son environnement de sa
famille de ses expériences
j'estime être assez fort pour ne pas
être réduit à un simple problème il n'a
pas toujours connu des grosses voitures
avec chauffeurs distingue mauvais élève
turbulent jeune homme il était plutôt
révolutionnaire
je n'ai pas d'idole à proprement parler
les personnages historiques m'ont
toujours fasciné d'histoire de france
par exemple
mais j'admire dans ton bacheliers sur le
tard à 22 ans il se découvre une âme de
militants en l'espace d'une vingtaine
d'années s'est transformé en un homme
politique rusé ne poursuivant qu'un seul
objectif la chancellerie sa vie privée
tumultueuse aurait pu tout gâcher
trois divorces quatre mariages mais
l'allemagne n'est pas l'amérique et on
le compare aujourd'hui davantage à tony
blair cap bill clinton avec ses
propositions sur la justice sociale ou
l'emploi des jeunes
il a réussi à incarner le changement
bien qu'il soit resté souvent dans le
flou le plus tôt
justin qu'une des mandats des problèmes
je pense être bien placé pour comprendre
les problèmes du peuple un les jamais
oublier mes racines je sais à qui j'ai
un programme politique est conçu pour
les gens s'est imposé comme ma mère par
exemple ma situation personnelle a
évolué c'est sûr je souhaite toujours me
consacrer aux classes les plus
défavorisées
il a passé pendant des mois
ces samedis dimanches sont les planches
l'explosion du chômage depuis la
réunification lui a donné l'occasion de
mieux se faire entendre du monde ouvrier
lassés des promesses non tenues du
championnat comme le week-end avec sa
nouvelle et tendre épouse il a donné
l'image d'un homme en qui on peut avoir
confiance
c'est la veille ce défaut ce nouveau
l'été réponse est sa principale qualité
là elle doit réfléchir un peu
sa qualité première est sont les choses
il a une crainte intuition elle est il
très bien communiquer convaincre et
séduire
c'est une dent de la nature chez lui ce
qui n'est pas donnée par la nature c'est
le bon geste pour baptiser un bateau
malgré les vifs encouragements de part
et d'autre
madame fraudeurs devra s'y reprendre à
trois reprises avec le temps elle
progressera
gerhard schröder n'est pas arrivée au
sommet d'un jour à l'autre il a gravi
les échelons un à un mais n'a jamais
oublié son passé d'enfant mode est un
enfant du peuple qui a toujours un geste
fraternel pour sa famille d'origine
qu'il ne devra pas délaisser hors champ
des caméras
en arrivant au pouvoir léguer lerner
bonsoir où en est on des sondages sont
eu l'impression que ça se resserrait
j'ai maintenant semble s'écarter les
sondages entre les deux principaux
candidats
bonsoir claude l'écart ce soir est
toujours en faveur de grh fraudeurs les
différents sondages lui donnent entre 2
et 5 points d'avance mais grâce
fraudeurs ne crie pas victoire ce soir
il a bien raison car les sondages n'ont
pas très bonne réputation ici en
allemagne se sont fourvoyés à trois
reprises ces derniers mois et notamment
en saxe-anhalt les sondages n'avaient
pas vu venir la montée de l'extrême
droite qui a atteint dans ce land la
hauteur de plus de 14% et puis rappelez
vous il ya quatre ans tout le monde
donnait helmut kohl gagnant vous savez
ce qu'il en est
tout le monde donne et helmut kohl
perdant et vous savez ce qu'il est ce
qu'il en est advenu il me colle a bien
évidemment remporté de fort peu cette
élection il ya quatre ans cela dit les
sondages sont sûrs d'une chose c'est du
taux de participation il sera très élevé
comme tous les quatre ans on attend une
participation électorale de plus de 80%
alors on s'oriente vers quoi si on peut
faire des pronostics c'est à dire vers
une coalition des deux grands partis ou
une alliance d'un grand parti avec un
petit notamment les verts ou les crèmes
gauche
comment ça commence a préfiguré trois
hypothèses première hypothèse une grande
coalition ce dont on parle de plus en
plus coalition droite-gauche qui
n'intéressent absolument pas helmut kohl
dans ce cas de figure le chancelier
prendra sa retraite
deuxième hypothèse une alliance spd
verts
là c'est l'inconnu et puis troisième
hypothèse c'est le déjà vu avec helmut
kohl qui reviendrait qu'ils
continueraient qu'ils poursuivraient
après ses années passées au pouvoir avec
les libéraux
un parti qui le soutient plus ou moins
en tout cas les libéraux du fdp sont
indispensables à une cause s'il veut
rester au pouvoir
merci olivier alors deuxième chapitre de
notre dossier concertée
à l'allemagne le volet économique nous
allons voir successivement deux chefs
d'entreprise français et allemands
tout d'abord près de la fccq un patron
français qui a choisi de s'implanter en
allemagne de l'est profitant ainsi de la
réunification
voyez le reportage de philippe rochot et
pierre moscovitch la sculpture à la
gloire du travail qui était là du temps
du communisme est resté même si
aujourd'hui c'est un français qui a
racheté cette usine de peignage de la
laine dans la banlieue perdue de light
sich bernard de montagut fait partie des
quelques dizaines de chefs d'entreprise
français qui ont osé reprendre les
usines vétustes de l'ancienne rda vendu
presque aux enchères après la chute du
communisme
cette entreprise date de 1872 au moment
de la chute du mur et 1400 personnes et
au moment où nous avons repris
d'entreprise 450 personnes donc il y
avait un espoir très important
à partir du moment où il y avait une
privatisation possible de cette
entreprise
aujourd'hui bernard de montagut
travaille seul avec une centaine
d'ouvriers est-allemand il est satisfait
de la concertation permanente qu'il y a
dans l'entreprise de la flexibilité et
du sentiment du personnel d'appartenir à
une famille
les ouvriers de leur côté sont rassurés
quand on a su qu'un investisseur
français racheté l'usiné nous dit la
responsable du comité d'entreprise
quand on a vu qu'il voulait développer
la production et qu'il était sincère nos
craintes se sont transformés en espoirs
pendant cinq ans l'entreprise a été
déficitaire mais depuis deux ans et
l'enregistrent des bénéfices et
contribue à faire revivre cette région
autrefois prospère avant la guerre le
premier objectif était d'avoir une base
industrielle en allemagne afin de
développer notre part de marché
ce que nous avons d'ailleurs réalisé
puisque nous avons augmenté notre part
de marché de 40%
la deuxième chose c'est d'avoir une tête
de pont sur les pays de l'est
une tête de pont qui paraît solide quand
on sait que d'autres entreprises
françaises ont fait faillite dans
l'ancienne rda
mais une tête de pont qui permet surtout
de faire travailler les ouvriers de
cette partie de l'allemagne où le
chômage frappe plus de 20% de la
population
alors en écho à ce reportage de philippe
rochot voici un patron allemand conseil
en entreprise installée en région
parisienne et qui a plus en plus de
travail car il ya de plus en plus des
échanges franco allemands mais il faut
pour cela aussi harmoniser les pratiques
reportage jean paul s'appelle philippe
deslandes
on l'appelle quand ça coince entre
français et allemands se consultent en
est à cologne connaît bien les
entreprises des deux pays
il s'est spécialisé dans les
coopérations franco allemande
exemple ici chez metaleurop au bout de
dix ans de cohabitation on a fini par se
comprendre mais le médiateur continue de
rapprocher les dirigeants dans les
réunions stratégiques
les réunions que l'on aborde
différemment selon son origine
éternel souffrance franco-allemande et
on retrouve le fameux cadre pour
l'allemande l'ordre du jour est sacrée
parce que comme ça
nous maîtrisons l'avenir nous savons le
résultat en fait qui va sortir de la
réunion dans une heure pour le français
c'est aberrant on n'a pas besoin de
faire une réunion si on sait déjà ce qui
va en sortir dans une heure de
metaleurop
c'est le leader européen dans les métaux
non ferreux la fusion c'est leur métier
leur mariage ils l'ont réussi
mais une fois sur deux les union
franco-allemande finissent mal quand les
problèmes surgissent les clichés
reviennent au galop
au début c'était vraiment le sentiment
que les allemands imposent quelque chose
en français et ça fait maintenant on
travaille fort monique et ce n'était pas
le cas
encadrement huit cantons se comptent les
allemands sont venus c'était vraiment
comme comme on dit toujours al mohannad
en files vraiment un rouleau compresseur
le rouleau compresseur côté allemand le
petit malin côté français deux méthodes
de travail opposées un malentendu
culturel le même mot peut avoir un sens
très différents dans les deux langues
pour le français le concept c'est plus
une idée
donc quand allemands et français se
rencontrent pour parler d'un concept
mais ils vont pas se comprendre
forcément parce que le français arrive
dans la réunion avec des idées assez
ouverte
alors que l'allemand a déjà une idée
fixe qu'en français et allemands
finissent par accepter leurs différences
le compromis est rentable metaleurop a
vu son bénéfice doublé l'an dernier
ça veut dire qu elle pas partir de nos
deux cultures française et allemande on
est capable de toucher la quasi-totalité
des cultures européennes
bon il fait sombre et donc d'avoir une
croissance de nos parts de marché
assurer sur sur un marché qui va
signifier progressivement pour ce
consultant beaucoup de travail en
perspective les rapprochements vont se
multiplier avec l'arrivée de la monnaie
unique
déjà depuis le début de l'année le
nombre de sociétés allemande rachetée
par des français a augmenté de 50% alors
selon le résultat des élections
allemandes la relation politique entre
nos deux pays sera sans doute modifié
voire plus difficile ainsi le ministre
monsieur hubert védrine déclarait à la
fin du mois d'août
l'allemagne réunifiée défend ses
positions sans complexe je ne dis pas
qu'il est devenu moins européenne mais
elle est comme elle est la france elle
n'en rajoute
pourtant l'histoire politique récente
s'est largement illustré par des couples
au plus haut niveau des deux états
commentaire jean-marc il ose les larmes
de helmut kohl aux obsèques de son ami
françois
la croix de fer sur les champs-elysées
et la brigade franco-allemande qui
partira plus tard pour sarajevo dans la
famille europe les grands sentiments les
rapports de confiance et les sourires
contraint après les bruins épisodique
comme à bruxelles en mai dernier lors du
lancement politique de l'euro un vrai
couple en somme mais franco allemand à
l'origine non pas un mariage d'amour
mais deux raisons un contrat imposé à
l'histoire par la volonté politique de
conrad adenauer et charles de gaulle et
signé à l'elysée en 63 pour qu'après
trois guerres en un siècle français
allemands construisent ensemble un
avenir européen
les mains dans les poches du socialiste
helmut schmidt sur le perron de l'elysée
aux côtés de son ami giscard un couple
moins formel une amitié bien utile pour
défendre les monnaies d'une europe
ébranlée par la crise du pétrole et
accompagner la naissance d'un futur
géant airbus mitterrand kohl cette fois
ci le socialiste est à paris et le
couple reste unie françois mitterrand
ira au parlement allemand pour faire
savoir aux soviétiques face à leurs
missiles la france comme les etats-unis
se tenait aux côtés de l'allemagne
et puis toujours au long de l'europe la
mémoire réconcilier avec l'avenir les
deux présidents main dans la main en
souvenir des sept cent mille morts de
verdun la chute du mur la tiédeur
française face à la réunification et un
début de cavalier seul de la grande
allemagne dans les balkans feront
craindre un moment le retour des
soupçons mais le besoin d'europe sera le
plus fort un président français qui
aiment la bière un chancelier allemand
qui ce jour là aurait préféré son verre
de blanc même si les clichés se brisent
le couple franco allemand devra
surmonter bien des défis avec l'arrivée
de l'euro puis celle des futurs membres
de la grande europe c'est le président
bonsoir regardez ces images certes
assuré parce que c'est de l'émotion ce
qui me frappe c'est depuis général de
gaulle le chancelier adenauer
ensuite vous même avec messieurs schmid
puis le président mitterrand avec
monsieur paul
au fond vous êtes à chaque fois deux
partis différents vous pourriez être
opposés sur beaucoup de choses mais vous
avez une volonté politique commune arc
qu'est ce qui faisait que ça marchait
bon d'abord il se trouve qu'on était de
partis politiques différents pas
tellement le général de gaulle et
adenauer c'est vrai qu'ils font pour war
l'un et l'autre mais helmut 8 et moi
c'était les deux tendances peu d'un
mitterrand et kohl la même chose d'abord
je crois que c'est parce que nos sujets
d'intérêts ne sont pas des sujets de
politique intérieure et nos différences
principales dans nos partis sont
porteurs de sujets de politique
intérieure
ensuite nous avions se croient les uns
les autres sentiment d'une
extraordinaire nécessité c'est à dire
que l'entente franco-allemande la
réconciliation d'abord du temps de de
gaulle montante du temps de 2008 et moi
même ça répondait à une nécessité
quelque chose dont nous savions qu'il
fallait le réussir et donc puisqu'on
était d'accord sur la nécessité
on la faisait ensemble alors comment
expliquez vous que ça marche moins bien
entre jacques chirac elle ne coule je
crois pour des deux raisons la première
c'est que c'est moi nécessaire quand
même l'euro dont la deuxième moitié du
xxème siècle qui se termine ça a été la
période dans laquelle on a construit la
paix en europe
c'était nécessaire à partir du moment où
ça a été fait on a peut-être moins
ressenti la nécessité de l'entente
franco allemand
parce que maintenant l'entente franco
allemande elle est indispensable pour
réussir l'europe
si nous voulons que l'europe sorte de sa
situation actuelle où elle ne fonctionne
pas très bien où les tables sont des
crises mondiales comme on le voit à
l'heure actuelle il faut faire des pas
en avant et cherchez pas en avant en
effet il n'ya plus le même accord entre
la france la glace est ce à dire que la
nouvelle génération politique pardon
mais les plus jeunes sont moins motivés
historiquement gérait que vous n'étiez
bien sûr parce que nous avions connu la
fin des grands drames
je vais dans notre mémoire la mémoire
nos impressions qu'ils ont formées il y
avait la falda guerre et les privations
y avait la déportation les violences
toutes espèces donc nous voyons un peu
ce qu'il fallait faire à partir d'un
drame tandis que la nouvelle génération
va le voir ce qu'il faut faire ça mais
de voir partir d'une situation qui est
dans une large mesure apaisées
alors je crois que l'idée qu'il faut
savoir penser que l'europe
réconciliatrice du passé et c'est fait
mais l'europe nécessaires pour préparer
le 21e siècle
elle existe encore ça reste à faire
alors est-ce que vous pensez que va se
substituer au duo au couple franco
allemand sur deux trépieds où il y aura
la grande bretagne l'allemagne et la
france devront alors que c'est utile
d'abord c'est c'est un traité parce
qu'il y en a d'autres
oui on peut pas exclure l'italie élite
est fallacieux pour des lords ni
l'espagne mais l'ordre des puissances
européennes
c'est un allemand de la france 3
l'italie
quatre wagons de montagne 5 l'espagne
donc on voit que d'abord les deux pays
tête et puis pour la course en tête
c'est la france et l'allemagne qui ne
s'entendent pas il n'y aura pas de
progrès de l'union d'europe et c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans les élections
allemandes
la question qui est importante pour nous
c est ce que le futur chancelier donnera
à l'entente franco-allemande son rôle
dans la poursuite de l'union européenne
et ça ça dépend pas tellement du parti
politique que de la conviction intime
conviction personnelle personnel alors
nous savons que c'est le cas pour helmut
kohl incontestablement nous le savons
moins pour gerhard schröder et j'y vais
regarder tout à l'heure le portrait que
j'ai montré aux téléspectateurs il est
difficile de répondre aujourd'hui
alors je crois les idées simples qu'on
doit avoir c'est de se dire bon les
lectures allemands de se la faire des
allemands c'est pas de calais ont voté à
leur place du point de vue économique ça
ne changera pas grand chose pour nous du
point de vue de l'union politique de
l'europe nous savons nous allons
chercher là c'est léo qui gagnent nous
le savons moins j'ai le respect des deux
chercheurs
monsieur le président merci et réponse
dimanche soir nous l'avons constaté il
ya quelques minutes de nombreux hommes
d'affaires allemands vivant en france si
vision même noué des liens affectifs
forts
ainsi nous avons rencontré un homme qui
s'est installé en france depuis près
d'un quart de siècle qui a épousé une
femme originaire de la région d'arles et
pour cet allemand qui nous connaît bien
les deux peuples ne peuvent se contenter
de bonnes relations commerciales il faut
aller au delà
valérie gage et pascal couillaud pour le
reportage caroline l'arlésienne
les relations franco allemandes ne sont
pas un simple jeu de balancier
diplomatique mais une réalité
quotidienne
voilà six ans qu'elle a épousé mathias
né en ex allemagne de l'est
ensemble ils ont une petite tessa âgée
de trois ans mathias est tombé amoureux
de paris lors d'un voyage scolaire
il a fait toutes ses études supérieures
en france et a choisi de s'y installer
il ya plus de vingt ans malgré quelques
difficultés d'intégration
je crois que la france fait partie des
pays de deir rien donc qui ne rendent
pas forcément la plus facile donc il est
beaucoup plus facile que tu as
connaissance des gens en allemagne
dick la sdr le petit ours blancs ne
laisse pas tessa de glace elle comprend
l'allemand et le parlent déjà un peu
presque instinctive nom d'ayman
catégorie coup donné un ordre sur ton
vraiment impératif sans équivoque pour
appuyer une demande donc le bois du bien
bien parfois et ensuite il comme pour
maintenir les liens avec l'allemagne il
y à la famille les voyages et une fois
par semaine un repas d'outre-rhin
matthias a aussi créé il ya cinq ans un
club franco allemand des affaires
il s'inquiète du refroidissement des
relations entre les deux pays
pour lui l'après-guerre agissait comme
un moteur peut-être et des générations
qui vont reprendre le flambeau qui vont
reprendre des idées nouvelles mais j'ai
quand même un doute parce que toute une
génération d'hommes d'affaires dans
politiques qui ont oeuvré durant les
trente dernières années sont en train de
prendre leur retraite
mathias et caroline bauer élèves leur
fille dans un esprit d'ouverture sur
l'europe
ces langues et toutes ces cultures elles
grandiront avec l'euro la paix en
héritage le régulièrement soir vous êtes
tellement direct en bourse avec
correspondant en france de la rd pendant
dix ans vous nous connaissez bien vous
êtes tellement alors qu'est ce que nous
avons en commun qu'est ce que nous avons
différents la différence certainement la
question de l'identité l'identité
allemande est une question très
difficile pour les allemands à
comprendre eux mêmes c'est pourquoi que
eux ils ont tendance à se dire nous
sommes pas allemand nous sommes
européens
mais je crains que les allemands sont
plus allemand qui le croient eux-mêmes
de l'autre côté les français disent
'nous nous avons l'identité de la france
mais nous sommes très européens parce
que nous voyons la nécessité de l'europe
deuxièmement nous avons une différence
des méthodes dans la question de traiter
la politique des questions de la société
chez nous c'est le consensus qui est
très important c'est pourquoi que je
crois que si nous allons avoir un
chancelier schröder ou un chose il est
cool ça va pas changer grand chose dans
notre politique étrange
r dans notre politique avec la force de
notre politique européenne
même dans les questions de politique
économique
ça ne va pas changer tellement chez vous
vous avez un gouvernement jospin qui
décide les 35 heures qui décident de
d'employer les jeunes chez nous on donne
la liberté au marché et pas à l'état
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
ensemble
on ne repère ce qu'on est européen au
même niveau dans nos sentiments dans nos
actes d'après vous je crains que non le
plus important c'est d'être plus
européen sur la question économique
alors il ya un grand problème en ce
moment c'est qu'est ce que nous allons
faire avec l'euro l'airbus l'airbus
devrait devenir un vrai consortium
européen mais les français veulent la
voir c'est à dire les 51% chez nous on
gibba il faut faire ça tous ensemble
deuxièmement je crois que la france et
l'allemagne ne sont plus le grand moteur
européen qu'ils ont été vous avez vu ça
avec le président giscard et je crois
qu'il soit très important de se
concerter dans la politique étrangère
européenne par exemple dans les
questions du kosovo merci beaucoup il
observe que nous avons le même fond de
décor pour faire nos journaux merci une
règle iker et voilà en conclusion de
cette sage spécial consacré à
l'allemagne quelques jours des élections
législatives de dimanche prochain
je vous invite à consulter si vous le
pouvez le site internet de france 2 qui
propose un dossier complet sur les
élections allemandes voici l'adresse de
ce site internet de france 2 pour
notamment les élections allemand à la
fin de ce journal je vous rappelle deux
principaux titres que nous avons
largement développée notamment l'
affaire de dopage dans l'équipe cycliste
festina qui était organisée une soigneur
believe hot wheels et ses carnets il
prouverait selon lui que richard
virenque s'est bien dopé et puis pour
les soins palliatifs l'accompagnement en
fin de vie
monsieur bernard kouchner annonce
dédoublement de moyens il faut renforcer
les soins palliatifs et ne souhaite pas
une action législative concernant
l'euthanasie dans quelques instants la
météo au design martinez et acide ou à
20h50 gérard clamens titres suivi de ça
se discute le dernier journal vous sera
présenté à zéro heure trente par bruno
roger petit demain à 7h50 dans les 4
vérités françoise laborde recevra le
professeur jean paul escande le
spécialiste du dopage à 13h carlo
gasquet rachid arhab à demain 20h
bonsoir merci